I understand the two of you may or may
not soon be meeting with theaters and
different distributors you know we may
oh you may okay so it is hot okay we're
all right okay not with distributors not
oh why we ready to go that yeah well
there's a we are meeting there be
distributors this won't be out before
tonight so there are distributors there
are people who are coming to see
Anderson bench tonight but we're talking
about a meeting with with theaters I've
done this one time before can we also
interject real quick certainly we can
what would we like to say well we like
to say the royal we right you have to
kind of go back to how the vaudeville
days were turning mean and then that
kind of gives people a little bit more
insight which is taking in to the road
shows doing the Mike Todd things was it
call to trucking a truck and pony truck
and pony show what's the expression it
was a dog and pony dog and pony show dog
and pony there was a try a bus and truck
was uh right when when you do when there
was also theater it's a bus and truck or
you pedal pedaled so they had theater
owners that would pedal they would
bicycle and I would start head of their
print right the next theater and they
they owned groups of theaters and so
it's um there are still theater owners
there are theater owners like are still
there are still see Santa owners there
are theater owners like that in the
south or the southern region I don't
know many in the north but anyway that
would work at own theaters and so back
then you would bicycle one you would
start off at one theater and that real
was bicycle to the next theater so you
could start the movie in that theater so
they would own one print this kind of
thing you know I actually did that right
you buy sekilde well i took i was in my
Dodge truck but yeah I but that's gonna
say but that's where that comes from ms
from the original single screen movie
theater owners and it was called
bicycling right pedaling you'd pedal
from one place to the other anyway go
ahead with you so that's a no that's
that's where things a chance right this
educational moment brought to my time
vice
uh there's a I I believe that there's a
way around everything there's a way
around it that the the entire industry
has changed it's it's a it's easier to
make movies now the only thing it's not
easier to do now is is to get
distribution because the same people are
in control of distribution and God bless
them is nothing wrong with with that but
its its corporate people or not
necessarily creative people non creative
people at the very last stage of a
creative process that makes no sense
that by the time you get to right just
before you're going to bring the
birthday cake out with the candles on it
you've got somebody with a fire
extinguisher right like on you can't
have that out here well wait a minute
why it's a birthday cake with candle no
no you can't do that their children out
there yes it's a child's birthday don't
you understand it's a little bit of a
tangent but so what we're trying to do
34 years ago I and a group of people
recognized a flaw in fundraising and it
was very much the same thing people
would raise money and by the time the
money was just about ready to go where
it needed to go someone else got a hold
of it and it didn't go to the right
place or someone took something off the
top and it didn't it just it was a
flawed system so for people started
something called the Children's Miracle
Network and in less than 15 years we
became the single largest children's
charity in the world and we still are
because we didn't know any better than
to have somebody with a fire
extinguisher blowing the candles out
before Johnny got to make a wish okay so
what we believe now is that there are
tremendously expensive
chains out there that are owned by
people who are in the movie business
they just spent they're on the hook for
40 50 million dollars for a Cineplex
because they want to be in the movie
business because they love the old
yeller and they love the Godfather and
they loved Harold and Maude and they
loved Herbie the Love Bug and loved and
loved and loved and loved and loved but
now because they have a mortgage and
because they have a loan and because
they they are now being forced to be
more in the business model than the show
model and I believe that to be true do I
have anything to back that up no but for
me it seems like common sense well this
makes sense so I think there's a way to
make a deal to distribute films directly
to cinema owners rather than have to go
this way which for me seems like the
long way around the barn just go right
to the people who are selling popcorn
and offer them content offer them a way
to put butts in seats but offer them a
way to be back in the show part of show
business so that's what that's what
we're involved in right now and it may
we may be we may be barking howling at
the moon I have no idea but I don't I
it's worth a try right we have to and
it's that's the fun part of it and I
think that we both are like-minded in
the sense that we have to make it back
to it being an event and that's why I
bring up vaudeville it was always the
juggler before the show or this or that
before the show and that's what there's
a lot of connecting parts that we're
talking about but it's connecting with
those theater owners who have been in
business since the 1920s 30s and 40s
their family these are the grandchildren
of people who started who built the
first theater right and it's really
taking them the content and then
creating this event then I want to say
at all because there's certain
connecting elements that we're doing
better there's a lot there's a whole lot
to it it is
roadshow type yeah venue
you